un guiño a los supremacistas blancos del
presidente de eeuu cuando se le preguntó
si le diría a los grupos de milicias de
extrema derecha que se mantuvieran al
margen y que no hayan dieran violencia a
las ciudades como portland que llevan
meses albergando protestas
donald trump eludió el tema casi todo lo
que veo es el ala izquierdista las twin
nature no de la ala derecha y estoy
dispuesto a hacer cualquier cosa quiero
ver la paz como quieres llamarlos
supremacistas blancos y proud voice
arboix apártense y estén preparados los
productos voice un grupo paramilitar de
extrema derecha se apresuraron a
celebrar la frase del presidente
publicando en sus canales de redes
sociales comentarios con la respuesta de
trump el candidato demócrata a la casa
blanca publicó un tweet diciendo que
ésta era la américa de donald trump esta
no es la primera vez que tran no condena
a los supremacistas blancos en 2017 se
negó a condenar a los nacionalistas y
otros grupos de directa después de que
un coche se estrellara contra los
contramanifestantes en charlottesville
matando a heather hey jr de 32 años soy
el tipo tenías gente que era muy buena
de ambos lados
creo que hay culpa en ambos lados no
tengo ninguna duda al respecto y tú
tampoco tienes alguna idea los analistas
ven la negativa del mandatario
republicano a condenar una vez más a los
supremacistas blancos como un llamado a
las armas el reconocimiento
probablemente apelará su base en lugar
de cambiar a los votantes de bando